Fox News did town halls with the Ohio
Senate candidates that's Democrat Tim
Ryan currently a congressman and
Republican candidate J.D Vance during
the Tim Ryan portion of the Town Hall
Tim Ryan did not back down from the Fox
News mob and this is really interesting
to see it's it's quite impressive in
fact this seems to be a stacked audience
some may be Democrats but the Lion's
Share of the noise certainly was not a
pro-democratic that's for sure and Tim
Ryan turned what were initially booze
into at least some cheers on the topic
of January 6. take a look at this listen
to the initial jeers and look at how he
turns it around and we'll talk about
what he does they storm the capital on
January 6th they beat up 140 police
officers killed killed one okay they
killed what they killed one
we all we all we all watched we all
watch the we all watch the video okay so
they boo but here he turns it around
I'll watch a video and I okay
let him finish please and I work I'm
happy to have this conversation I'm not
afraid to have this conversation these
are the conversations we need to have in
this country I welcome you guys let's
just be respectful but I'm not afraid to
stand here and defend my position
um on January 6th 140 cap I I sit on the
subcommittee that funds the capital
police
these are my friends 140 of them got
hurt and some of them still can't go
back to work because they were beat up
with lead pipes they were sprayed with
pepper spray they were beaten with
flagpoles okay they were trying to
overthrow the government they were
trying to stop the peaceful transition
of the government what else were they
doing there are they going to kill Mike
Pence right you want to kill Nancy
Pelosi now somebody's beating up Nancy
Pelosi's husband with a hammer
JD Vance raised money for the
insurrectionist he made several social
media posts to raise money for them now
again I don't care what your politics
are but Americans should say
no we have to say no to that we're going
to try to get as many questions all
right so a smattering of Applause what
turned the tide here for him it's a
couple different things number one Tim
Ryan stood his ground he stood his
ground he said hold on
I'll go up against any of you on the
facts but let's do it respectfully he
backed up what he was saying it helped
that he was telling the truth and then
he found common ground with the audience
and we're going to have I've told you
all before we're very close to releasing
a white paper about how to have
conversations about politics that can be
contentious we're going to give it away
for free we've been working on it for
weeks giving it away soon
um and finding common ground is a really
critical part of this
um one other element to this Tim Ryan
also getting Applause when talking about
uh his answer on energy policy tax that
President Biden mentioned a tax on oil
companies profits are you for that
um I haven't looked at exactly what he
wants to do I think the fact that oil
companies are making huge profits and
having stock BuyBacks right now while
average person here is paying nearly
four dollars a gallon I think that's
wrong and I think we need to crack down
we need to crack down on it
we're gonna move on
so I mean listen uh Tim Ryan is not the
most Progressive but he was able to find
common ground with a lot of these folks
and I think that that is instructive in
many ways unfortunately if you believe
the polling JD Vance is now up by about
2.2 points on average the important
message is if you vote in Ohio make damn
sure that you participate in this
election because Tim Ryan could win this
thing the chances that your login
credentials have been leaked in a data
breach are higher than you might think
but you can actually check if you go to
aura.com Pacman you can try Aura for
free our sponsor Aura scans the dark web
for your personal information login
credentials social security number and
sends you alerts sign up and you could
be shocked to see how many alerts you
get on Aura one of our team members
found his login credentials in three
different data breaches now of course he
changed his passwords right away I've
told you before about one of my accounts
getting hacked scary feeling but Aura
also does so much more by automatically
requesting the removal of information
from data search engines giving you fast
alerts on suspicious credit inquiries or
it has password management malware
protection for all of your devices and
Aura also helps you manage what your
kids can do on their devices by
restricting certain apps it's really
like a Swiss army knife of online
security and you can try Aura for free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman the
link is down below